padres and rockies getting set from
coors field in denver colorado today the
padres will face the young left-hander
kyle freeland 27 year old making his
second start of the season joey lucasi
on the mound for the padres 27 year old
making his second start he needs quick
innings early two good base runners
story away from second and blackman off
from first payoff pitch
and kemp will send it right side where
profar picks it his throw will be close
but just in time bang bang play as
profile is able to throw out matt campin
and the inning chris owings looking for
his first hit as a rocky getting the
start at second base to
get the right-handed bats in the lineup
next pitch fastball lined by the diving
try of profar at second hampson on his
way to third he'll get in there standing
chris owings has his first hit as a
rocky man on the corners with one out
here in the second now first and third
with one out and the right-handed
hitting drew butera at the plate
this is in the air the shallow ride
should be deep enough though myers has
it here comes
and he is going to stride home at the
first run outstanding two-stroke
approach by drew butera exactly what i
was talking about story an infield hit
his first time rockies with a run in
here in the second
and this gets by the first baseman
france come on down
chris owens two to nothing colorado he
just looked like he whipped on that
absolutely it wasn't that bad for it
didn't skip over there there goes some
high fives air high fives i should say
like seeing the air high fives all the
time charlie blackman who singled to
left center field has two one and two
out against luke casey
and this is uh base hit right center
field owens will score story to third
three nothing colorado the padres flat
cannot get out
number 19. it's impossible this is just
to wear you down in it that's what the
rockies have done to the casey and
that'll be it three nothing rockies
charlie didn't crush it but got enough
of it to bloop it into right center and
now cal cuatro will face matt kemp 46
career home runs for kemp against the
rockies 3-1
and this is lifted right center field
and deep and matt kemp has hit one for
the rockies now
make it for nothing
we have liftoff
282
career home runs now for matt kim matt
kemp with the home run and the rockies
build on the lead they're up four to
nothing his first long ball of the year
like seeing that in rocky's purple four
nothing rockies freeland trying to make
it his third consecutive one two three
inning
great catch by story
how about that play trevor story keeps
on doing it defensively my goodness what
a play again
give it to trevor not only for his
offensive exploits but obviously for the
capture a moment ago
high drive deep left field take a good
look you won't see it for long
trevor story home run number four of the
season
home opener day two at home it doesn't
matter he flat out rakes
127 career home runs now for trevor
126 of those have come while he has been
a shortstop he's one out nobody on in
the fifth fly ball again to left field
long run for hampson and aronato and
foul ground nolan with the sliding catch
help him up he got it help him up that
is one of his all-time
plays he ran about half a mile that's
what i was gonna say from where he
started to be able to catch this like he
did knowing that that wall is coming up
i'll go ahead and slide that is an
unbelievable play well chris owens two
for two first two hits in a rockies
uniform
and this is a humpback lighter that'll
get down he's three for three matt kemp
scores six nothing
colorado
anytime you don't get a start every day
you get a couple starts a week been
sitting on an over coming in and then
tonight you go three for three right out
of the gate it just takes a lot of the
pressure self-induced pressure on
yourself chris owings has a three-hit
knight rockies lead it six to nothing a
one-two to machado
ground ball up the middle story dives
they're gonna get one on the first
double play how about that turn
story having a huge night on both ends
yet again double play what a play by
story what a turn by owings and the
stretch by mcmahon
six four three the padres are done
ground ball tough play no it's got it
nolan the first ow in first base
how about the leather tonight
that left side impenetrable live drives
pop flies ground balls forget about it
playing a little short stop as a third
baseman diving just like trevor had to
start that double play comes up and
fires and gets pro far gorgeous look at
this pops right up
nolan
guns out pro far the out will stand
and what a play by arenado
ball set to center field david dahl
moving back looking up and it is gone a
home run
trent grisham gets his third home run in
a padres uniform dead center field
and the padres are on the board
get their first run of the night it
comes here to lead off the top of the
eighth inning for trent bishop kingly to
buyers
he's got a
ball game over
and a complete victory for colorado
tonight behind kyle freeland a six to
one final great bounce back after the
disappointment of last night trevor
story offense defense nolan great game
defensively as well the rockies even the
series with the san diego padres
winning in
fine fashion tonight 6-1